Không chỉ có cao mẹ ra của định,
Hà Nội đang thường nghiệp thêm một lớp quan sát mới từ trên không.
Tư thằng sau Hà Nội thường nghiệp dùng UWA để giám sát chất tự lối thị
tại một số phường ở hoàn kếm và tế hồ.
Tư lâu cao khoảng năm mẹ,
thì bị có thể phát hiện các tỉnh 1 bất thường
như xe dừng lỗ xa quý định.
Un tắc sào thông, bản hình dòng, lẫn chiếm lòng đường,
về hệ, phóng tập kết giác thải trải phép,
và chuyên thì gạy chực tiếp về chú tâm thông tin chỉ huy quà mạc 1 gờ năm gờ.
Hãy có tình huống bất thường,
kẻ thống cửa đồng nhẹ thì bị chi, và mất lộ yêu tiên.
Sau khi được cán hộ sát nhật,
thông tin sẽ được chuyển đến lực lượng chiếc năng gần hiện chưởng.
Thinh ngành giò UWA về khi nhận phụ có thể được xử dụng,
làm cán cứ phụ cửa gềm chát, sự li đi phạm.
Hoa nghiệp dật là chết khai, các hiện tạm sát.
Cái dụng các thải thủ báo,
sức hiệu như phát hiện các bạn báo,
liên quan đến trải nổ,
các bạn báo liên quan đến các thủ tọng,
trong người pháp sụ biệt,
và thích chuyển dẫn là thật nghiệp là phát loa trên các thích đi.
Công báo cho người dân mắm được,
các thông báo trên các thích kể cả trong người phụ cửa đường.
Tổ thủ tế biệt này, tích cả thông báo cho người dân.
Theo kẻ hoạch, việc thí điểm,
cáo xa này đến ngày 3,3 cám.
Công ăn thịt của hành hộ dự kiến hoàn thiệt báo cáo năng giá,
trong phần chiến, để báo cáo bộ công an,
làm cứ sở xem sát cả năng chiến thải giải pháp này, trong phần tiến.